[Music]
it's that time of the month again I only
have reveals the 6-3 game for March 2017
- for the ps4 - for the ps3 and soon for
the beta as well this month we have
platformers a strange fought title a
clear station Vita masterpiece a fighter
and the sci-fi shooter which can all be
downloaded from Tuesday the 7th of March
as always let's kick off with those
offerings on the ps4 first off is the
critically acclaimed tearaway unfolded
created by the super talented Media
Molecule if you feel that this sounds
like a Vita game you're right but the
mechanics have been updated to fully
utilize the ps4 controller in addition
to typical button prompts you must also
push the switch card to perform spring
jump and swipe to create wind and even
directs the controller to create light
beam you'll be running around a paper
world attempting to deliver a very
important message this is a platformer
filled with loads of customisable
elements collectibles and mini quest all
with an innovative control scheme this
may not be the triple-a title you wanted
but this game is so unique that it
deserved your attention current
Metacritic score 81%
next up a disc jump a fast paced action
spot game that fits two to four players
against each of us in a frantic
combination of air hockey and tennis it
feels like a modern representation of
prong to me or a 3d version of wind
gemma's from 1994 players scramble to
retrieve and throw a glowing disc while
unleashing devastating abilities and
defending their end zone this has been
in beta status as quite a while as
high-horse entertainments finalized a
few elements well it looks like the
finish so before any reviews come out
why not try it for yourself and make
your own minds up before we move on to
the ps3 and Vita please do with a favor
and press subscribe we need your support
to grow but we're so proud of the three
and a half thousand grenadier is we have
alongside it anyway that's enough
begging for sub back to the free game
the first type on ps3 is under knight
inverse x late yes that's really a title
this is a 2d fighting game which reminds
me of King of Fighters if you're old
enough to remember
in in that heyday originally released in
2012 in Japan it took another three
years to finally make it to Europe what
you see here is definitely what you get
which is a heck of a lot of spicing
current Metacritic scoffs eighty percent
next on the ps3 is Earth Defense Force
2025 could you guess what it was from
the title this is a third-person shooter
released in 2014
you'll fill the boots of a soldier
tasked with keeping earth free of alien
bosses so expect a great deal of
shooting assault rifles chase those
rocket launchers grenade laser weapons
or the more you play at the most I fight
it become Metacritic has the ps3 version
of this game at 69% vastly outscoring
its ps4 counterpart so maybe it's a good
thing we didn't get this on ps4 so much
underutilized vita has two further
titles for you one of which is brilliant
the first saw is luma which is a cross
bike title so you can play on your ps4
off the s3 if you like luma is a modern
take on the isometric dungeon
platformers from the late 80s and early
90s this is filled with nods and winks
to all the retro games which probably
makes this one suitable for all the
gamers but I'd love to be wrong about
that
current Metacritic score is 73 percent
this one could surprise you
but I don't expect many people to try
finally said it is our last offering of
the month and I cannot think it Crazy's
any higher drink box curios follows off
the masterpiece that is guacamelee with
this first-person heavily stylized hack
and slash title 7 takes the addictive
nature of fruit ninja and injects the
storyline and many RPG elements - this
game is bloody brilliant with
Destructoid and polygon dressing severed
9.5 and 9 respectively play this game
you won't regret it I promise
so that's it that's the six games we are
getting for March 2017 what will you be
picking up I'll be trying tear away and
I'll most definitely be getting back
into severed on my beloved Vita let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
i'm adam for playstation grenade i'll
see you next time
[Music]